[Musique]
bien le bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans la ville de corinne
bourgues capital de sa propre région
proche du kazakhstan elle marque la
frontière théorique entre l'europe et
l'asie
[Musique]
fondée en 1743 elle a un rôle militaire
et commerciale primordiale elle est à la
fois une forteresse aux frontières
méridionales de l'empiré russe et une
étapes commerciales importantes avec
l'asie centrale
aujourd'hui au ring bourg compte un peu
plus d'un demi million d'habitants
différentes populations s'y côtoient
depuis des temps anciens outre les
russes les tatars les bachkirs et les
casas qui sont principalement
représentés ce carrefour des cultures a
fourni à la russie différents artisanat
on les célèbre challes d'orenburg en
duvet de chèvre en plus une industrie
légère la région un important secteur
gazier et pétrolier
[Musique]
la ville d'oran gourgues abrite un
institut supérieur d'aéronautique
renommée nous sont sortis les premiers
pilotes qui ont survolé l'arctique et
l'antarctique
la ville a d'ailleurs porté pendant un
certain temps le nom d'un célèbre
aviateur vous valez ridge call of qui a
effectué le premier vol transpolaires au
dessus du pôle nord
[Musique]
c'est aussi ici que youri gagarine a été
élève et en 1963 en son honneur a été
créé la première école de jeunes
cosmonautes de l'urss
7000 kilomètres séparent orenbourg gay
la patrie de nos invités d'aujourd'hui
il s'appelle chance moussala et jacques
ma foi là et ils sont venus de kinshasa
capitale de la république démocratique
du congo pour s'adonner à leur passion
favorite la musique allons faire leur
connaissance
jacques oui bonjour bonjour ça va bien
oui oui ça valait bien rêver elle
dispose bien de venir ici merci mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait à orenbourg qu'est
ce que vous faites ici ah ben on fait
des bébés chante on danse c'est vrai les
pays à huy pour toi tu chantes nos deux
tu chantes aussi oui oui le bébé y
chantera encore
écoute mes chansons avec bon alors vous
chantez est-ce qu'on a un concert ce
soir au c soit oui mais maintenant là on
à répétition oui et génial et je vais
pouvoir vous écouter un
génial
et sympa alors oui ce qu'on a ici et si
c'est notre lieu de travail
c'est notre laboratoire et c'est ici
qu'on répète est con con con qu'on
élabore et avant d'aller jouer quoi je
vous présente fabrice fabrice bonjour
henrichon tu fais du tam-tam trois
saisons j'ai fait d'autres instruments
oui oui lesquels les films que
j'aimerais djembé d'encre là et vous
vous rendez vous b et je chante aussi et
moi j'ai chanté dans le souci évident
ceux ci n'ont jamais tout le monde
dansait avec l'asie
et alors comment s'appelle votre groupe
là vous êtes dit à tout le monde tous
les membres du groupe là aujourd'hui
nous ont mené à quatre donc il ya encore
et a osé qui n'est pas encore d'accord
nous alors vous êtes dont emi vous êtes
toujours tous les quatre c'est ça oui
locale comment s'appelle votre groupe
maracaibo c'est marc riboud en fait
c'est nous avons trouvé un peu quelque
chose de d'afrique inquiet parce que
j'ai un autre groupe qui s'appelle
kilimandjaro oui quand je voulais un peu
me débarquer dès qu'il est majeur je me
suis tombé sur le lac et la ville
beau
nom m'a plu j'ai dit moi
mais les gens te demande non
[Rires]
[Musique]
une question si vous jouez ou caen pour
qui vous fait des grands concerts de
combien de personnes c'est quoi comment
ça se passe
j'ai dit que je n'ai pas touché à cette
question ce jour là où il ya du pognon
et là là où on peut gagner de l'argent
mais normalement nous jouons beaucoup
plus dans le mariage ou un anniversaire
et est aussi une jourdan de vous pour le
grand public dans nos jours dans deux
festivals de musique c'est ça il y en a
beaucoup à ce mode et musique festive à
d'autres noms de festivals et de musique
aussi à d'autres festivals des
rencontres des conférences et à le le
fait des villes le fait d'aider des
villages
voilà quelle est votre répertoire vous
chantez quoi comme un site de musique
dont nous faisons le
pratiquement de pop oui le pop donc la
musique des années 80
90 donc 2000 et puis les variétés de
maintenant la donc voilà on essaie un
peu de mélange et parce que les riches
aiment beaucoup les variétés des années
80 alors vous chantez des musiques
russes aussi des chansons aux perçu aux
chansons russes en français et puis on
chante aussi en langue gaza stop et
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous allez
faire comme répétition on va on va
essayer un peu parce que non là on était
de préparer notre
single bientôt là quand vous avez vos
propres chansons oui mais voilà donc on
est tenté de préparer des enquêtes en
quelle langue the
way nous sommes en russie d'envoi dont
il faut irriguer les rues c'est d'abord
après les africains après
[Rires]
[Musique]
souviens toi t'es qui
cheetah
[Musique]
et
conditions
et tiens
ça n'a pas été trop difficile durant le
confinement durant là avec le vide au
début oui c'était un peu très compliqué
parce que nous on prend des concerts en
avant alors qu'il ya des gens qui nous
invite une année en avance ils perdent
avant cela la moitié déjà d'accord alors
et c'était quand le confinement qu'on a
commencé on a annulé parce qu'on a tous
et on était obligé dé remettre l'argent
aux gens c'est un peu difficile était
difficile où les deux premiers mois
c'était difficile mais après bon et vous
avez vous avez acquis à côté de ça
d'autres vous fait d'autres choses à
côté de ça parce que j'imagine que quand
les chansons sont à rater il fallait
bien gagner de l'argent qu'est-ce qu'est
ce que vous faites à côté on aimerait
bien rester à la maison parce que nous
on fait le concert seulement le vendredi
le samedi c'est vraiment c'est tout le
temps tout le temps ses nuits des jours
donc
le lundi on est là soit on est la
répétition soit on est à la maison soit
on a régalé les enfants donc que le
calme soit on fait rien d'assez calme et
des fois elle ne veut pas rester à la
maison
c'est un travail qu'est ce que tu fais
on jetterait c
une tresse africain tu fais des tresses
africaines c'est ça tu fais chez toi à
la maison où tu fais quelque part dieu
dans un studio a déjà un salon de beauté
c'est ça oui et toi qu'est ce que tu
fais le reste du temps bon j'ai fait pas
mal de choses pour nous pas mal de
choses j'ai fait deux on a une émission
à la télévision que j'anime avec les
gens et puis j'ai fait des coups de
petits coups dans
deux du théâtre des cours de théâtre
c'est donc j'apprends aux élèves le
français le biais du théâtre assez
intéressant tu pourras me tu pourras me
montrer ça aussi et oui si tu veux bah
ouais moi je veux savoir si on ira
d'autant salon beauté elle se montrera
sa
[Musique]
chance ça fait longtemps que tu es dans
son groupe 1 ça fait des siens 3-1 trois
ans déjà tu chantes tu chantais avant
mais non j'ai dansé avant tu dansais tu
faisais du tam tam et au réseau local et
afro jazz
donc tu avais déjà une expérience la
chanson et quand il t'a proposé de jouer
tu as dit génial et un ca rui
jacques ma foi l'année en 1980 à
kinshasa capitale de la république
démocratique du congo au sein d'une
famille composée de 38 frères et soeurs
son père est instituteur et sa mère
commerçante après l'école secondaire
jacques entame des études de théâtre et
se lance dans cette carrière invitée
pour participer à un festival culturel
il arrive pour la première fois en
russie à moscou en 2004 et décide d'y
rester ils travaillent quelque temps au
club français de moscou où il donne
notamment des cours de théâtre sur le
conseil d'une amie il part à
tcheliabinsk pour suivre une formation
de développement personnel il décide
alors de s'y installer et crée d'abord
un premier groupe de danse et de musique
afrique art puis un deuxième
kilimandjaro ce dernier groupe connaît
un grand succès et continue d'ailleurs à
exister à tcheliabinsk moscou et kazan
après dix ans à tcheliabinsk jacques
décide de revenir à moscou où il crée
encore un nouveau groupe maracaibo un
peu plus tard on lui propose de devenir
le directeur artistique d'un parc
d'attractions à orx qu un jour en
tournée dans la ville d'aurillac book il
recherche une jeune fille pour un
remplacement dans son groupe et c'est à
cette occasion qu'il rencontre chance
moussala alors étudiante chance
également congolaise est né en 1995 à
kinshasa d'un père peintre est une mère
vendeuse
après des études chimie biologie son
père décide de l'envoyer poursuivre ses
études en russie chance arrive en russie
en 2016 où elle se met au russe après
leur rencontre chance et jacques
s'installa au rainbow wii se marie en
2019 leur premier enfant jennifer neyt
en mai 2021 ils vivent avec jonathan
fils de jacques issu d'un premier
mariage jacques a une autre fille
jeanine qui étudie la peinture à moscou
[Musique]
chance et jacques sont chrétiens
baptistes de confession tous les
dimanches nos invités à assister à
l'office religieux chez un pasteur
qu'ils connaissent bien dans l'une des
cinq paroisses baptiste d'orenburg où il
se retrouve entre amis du même mouvement
chrétien évangélique
[Musique]
après la cérémonie jacques récupère les
enfants pendant que chance va travailler
nous avons suivi chance pour mieux
comprendre l'une de ses autres
occupations
à la chance raconte monsieur où est-ce
qu'on a c'est mon salon ça déboite et
enfin maîtresse africain c'est toi qui
l'a créé oui assez héroïque c'est une
mode il ya beaucoup de salons aurait
donc oui et à de novatel est je pense
une vingtaine d'heures
donc c'est vraiment une mode en russie
c'est un circuit et pourquoi bon je
pense que parce qu' il ya des stars qui
font des tresses nom qui fait détresse
afrique et oui après il fait des clips
oui non pas ça va générer oui oui non
c'est pour cela mais c'est
spécifiquement au rainbow ou même dans
la russie non un récit en fait dans la
rue lui tout le monde a la même coiffure
bateau m'a dit moi en fait j'aimerais
bien comprendre si ton salon s'il y en a
20 à côté pourquoi les gens viennent
chez toi bon parce que je suis africain
je suis là c'est qu'ils font les presses
donc tu es l'unique oui sur le côté avec
une vraie ans par ici un héros
est-ce que c'est difficile d'ouvrir une
société en russie
moi je pense c'est c'était facile
oui parce que ici un récit
ya pas différents sites yeresso pas
aussi peut ouvrir quel plaisir tu
trouves dans ton travail pourquoi tu
fais ce travail là bas premièrement j'ai
fait ça par amour que j'aime bien mon
travail est prêt et j'aime quand il
rentre chez moi et rendez rice après il
sort africaine
c'est après le travail que chance
retourne à la maison pour remplacer
jacques garder les enfants afin que
jacques puissent aller à l'école pour
s'adonner à son autre passion le théâtre
salut
[Musique]
comment ça commence
en apprenant la langue française par le
biais du théâtre donc avec le jeu
d'acteur avec geste unique que le façon
de parler donc bref
théâtre comme un moyen d'apprendre aux
élèves le français
au
[Applaudissements]
delà de ta méthode de travail est ce que
tu prévois peut-être de faire un
spectacle de théâtre jusque là
aujourd'hui donc on a commencé parce que
je n'ai déjà fernand dispatcher les
rôles aujourd'hui on a essayé un peu de
de
commencer à lire les textes on est dans
l'étape rêver les chansons qu'on a un
coût qu'on est en train d'apprendre
aussi puisque pour les spectacles est-ce
qu'on interdit de deux mètres sur scène
la blanche neige
[Musique]
pourquoi tu donnes ses courbes rock et
qu'elle est qu'est ce tu prends du
plaisir aussi à ça j'imagine oui parce
que
je suis passionné de théâtre et ses
passionnés simple donc j'ai fait autre
chose maintenant je fais la musique donc
de commencer la répression et être sur
scène m sur scène vraiment j'adore c'est
pour ça mais j'ai fait ça je vais pas ça
pour l'argent parce que
la colette certaines y est de 1 au mois
c'est
ce travail et être dans le goulet de ne
pas oublier mes notions
sur la scène voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
messieurs d'ombrie
machinisme
[Musique]
alors racontez moi un petit peu c'est
votre appartement vous êtes locataire
vous êtes propriétaire et si
vous êtes locataire alors qu'est-ce qui
vit dans cet appartement vous êtes avec
un petit garçon captivea voûte
jaune a ainsi compris tibet let wa ici
qu'est-ce que vous avez vous avez
d'autres enfants oui oui encore jennifer
et
jette non elle a 15 ans 15 ans d'accord
jennifer six mois avant elle fait ses
nuits tout va bien
[Musique]
comme encore prise est-ce que vous
accompagne dans l'airé dans les concerts
non
j'ai une question pourquoi au ring
bourgue je veux dire c'est quand même un
climat froid on est dans l'oural comment
vous êtes arrivé à tuer français est tué
du désir comme un russe c'est les même
question qu'on nous pose de fait vrai
chargé pourquoi en mauvaise passe qui
sait géographiquement stratégique
parce que nous faisons des concerts et
en russie et au kazakhstan alors pour
voyager de la lys nouveau genre à partir
d'ici à travers la russie dont pour
aller voyager
okaz un stade donc ses 200 kilomètres de
la frontière et hui et je suis dans la
ville qu'on appelle à trouver ce qui est
à partir de l'an voyage à travers tout
est d'accord dont ces géographiquement
donc bien placé non mais sans rire oui
encore elle le climat des ddd d'oreilles
boules de plus et plus de plus que celle
de moscou passe comment ce que fait très
froid mais pas se battre et x men et il
pleut beaucoup et
voilà
et c'est pas trop dur de s'installer en
russie vous êtes venus du congo c'est un
pays chaud vous arrivez en russie pays
froids qui est ce que c'est la
température est ce que c'est les gens
ont réellement oui à l'afrique effet
n'ont commencé que non là bas il fait
tellement chaud oui et ses vêtements en
effet une fois il faut s'habiller oui
oui vous êtes habitués
bompas avec le foie ou déjà wee cc m'a
pas seulement le chaud et le froid cc
c'est la langue c'est la langue la
langue voilà mais moi je trouve que si
par exemple quelqu'un qui pourrait
s'ouvrir et notre chemin donc si vous
voulez habiter en russie il faut savoir
la langue et la langue c'est la culture
donc si vous ne prenez pas la langue
donc si c'est là pour vous des caches
mois
nous avons laissé nos artistes se faire
beau il anime ce soir un mariage kazakh
où ils vont devoir mettre l'ambiance en
faisant le show
banier
[Musique]
en quoi
jacques qu'est ce que tu voudrais
découvrir en russie encore
en voir la diva stockera et voir aussi
kaliningrad et toi chance qu'est ce que
tu veux découvrir en russie
hello hello blanc le loup blanc oui
j'aime bon alors
il oublie d'accord jacques une question
difficile
comment tu te vois dans dix ans
[Rires]
dans dix ans je ne sais pas peut-être un
grand-père
et toi chance comment tu te vois dans
dix ans
forme d'affaires
je vous remercie on a passé un moment
extraordinaire de musique je vous
souhaite beaucoup beaucoup de bonnes
choses dans tous vos concerts et puis
une renommée internationale qui sait ok
merci merci merci à vous aussi merci
river nivea pour la gauche en tançant
bien
et pourquoi pas à dire merci
me
mais voilà notre émission touche à sa
fin nous l'avons passé avec deux
joyeuses invités chance et jacques qui
nous ont fait danser à offenburg sur des
rythmes effrénés de nouveaux lieux de
nouvelles personnalités toutes aussi
intéressantes vous attendre je vous dis
à très bientôt sur un terreau ans
[Musique]